mesdames messieurs bonsoir c'est
émouvant c'est une joie aussi déprécie
d'avoir été invité mais voilà j'ai sur
les cendres de la dette
je suis franco italien d'ici mon accent
est magicien et arômes ma mère est
française mon père a été sicilien
italien voilà donc je me présente un peu
et ça c'est pour vous raconter quelques
aventures quelques navigation que j'ai
pu réaliser v qu'on sait pour vous m
voilà une première heure slide c'est
celle-là ça permettre de visualiser un
peu le monde et que j'ai côtoyés depuis
depuis petit après quelques années un
arôme à ses côtés de rob mes parents
sont transférés en sicile et là j'ai
découvert vraiment la mer et c'était
foule durant c'était une passion mais
voici environ 11 ans avec un peu vers
les deux ans avec un optimiste un petit
dériveur un petit bateau de 2 mai 30 et
de quelques kilos de bois et avec ma
mère sur le sud des côtes siciliennes et
à la fin un voyage avec mon père que je
raconte est un peu plus à l'est de
taille et j'ai commencé après abba
étudier ces études scientifiques un bac
et scientifique après donc de lui passer
de la grille jantes à à palerme
l'université maîtrise en sciences de la
terre je suis devenu géologue
j'ai commencé à travailler et on peut
aussi lui aussi comme moniteur de voile
le mans c'était mon plaisir mais aussi
dans l'archéologie sous marine est
encore un peu une année encore dallas
dans la recherche d'hydrocarbures et un
prêt ni génie industriel donc la
géologie appliquée à l'ism industriel à
la médecine du travail
un moment et société et pendant que je
préparais une traversée une traversée du
pacifique sur un catamaran de sport a
décidé de s'associer de m'aider c'était
à la fin mon premier sponsoring j'étais
salarié pour préparer une aventure et
c'est ce jour là que j'ai décidé de
démissionner ce n'est peut-être pas un
bon exemple
mais c'était pour suivre une autre
phrase une autre passion à côté de la
géologie
c'était la navigation la mer et vivre en
fer entre guillemets mon métier et je
navigue depuis l'âge de 6 ans et après
un moment va j'ai grandi avec mon père
j'avais 21 ans on a décidé avec un petit
catamaran de place donc un catamaran de
sport un catamaran sans abri qui fait
environ 200 kg de poids de infectés une
aventure donc déjà pour moi c'était
plusieurs limites du fait que c'est le
thème de cette soirée à des passes et
c'était déjà limite humaine mais j'ai
aussi de le faire avec mon père et que
parfois ça va être aussi compliquée et
après aller au delà de notre limite
c'était cette aventure donc relier la
sicile
l'italie aux antilles en particulier la
martinique est non seulement faire un
exploit c'est des vignes c'était la
première fois que quelqu'un faisait un
si long parcours sur un si petit bateau
à la voile sans assistance mais on
voulait aussi amener message de le
message planétaire un message pour la
démocratie mais ça sur les respect des
droits humains n'emporte la couleur de
la peau en importe la religion et l'état
physique ou l'appartenance sociale
le mont voilà le message était contenu
dans le nom de ce bateau qui a reçu et
la première phase dès qu'il est exposé à
disposition universelle de séville
s'était les états unis du monde
united states of the world s était aussi
un message contre contre les guerres
pour la paix pour l'environnement et des
côtes siciliennes avec après plusieurs
jours de navigation
on a franchi encore une autre limite qui
était le passage des colonnes d'hercule
donc le passage de gibraltar
la sortie de la méditerranée le bateau
est exposé à des à l'exposition
universelle en 92 a sévi à l'espagne et
de là après on est arrivé on remet aux
îles canaries auzits des cap vert et la
dernière partie c'était six jours de
navigation en passant
du reste dans la tempête de l'ouragan
bruni et on est arrivé à schoelcher en
martinique où d'ailleurs je travaille
aujourd'hui pour une société alternative
sedin qui s'occupe de charters de
location de bateaux et après j'ai
continué donc j'ai voulu le faire tout
seul et ça pour moi c'était notre défi
est une autre limite à à passer et j'ai
posé un peu la repositionner la barre un
peu plus haute
donc j'ai voulu le faire avec un
catamaran plus petit et s'appelle
d'ailleurs une intensité de sos devoirs
de tous et je les fais tout seul et donc
d'italie jusqu'aux canaries c'est un
entraînement et après pour prendre la
décrocher la première mondiale j'ai dû
pour être homologuée par la fédération
internationale de voile est passé coupé
la ligne d'arrivée de la route du rhum
2002 et j'ai continué sans abandonner
goût donc un moment je me suis dit péter
très veut pas voir le temps dans ma vie
de faire plusieurs fois traversé dans
des conditions dures enocean difficile
qu'on le pacifique nord de ouest et est
et je me sentais prêt moment au vu de
l'expérience et j'avais fait d'attaquer
un record du monde une première mondiale
donc être le premier à traverser du
japon aux états unis toujours sur un
catamaran de plage sans cabine sans
escale sans assistance
et c'est dans cette traversée que je me
mets à la fin à un bon point j'ai réussi
en 72 jours de navigation et que je me
suis dit mais si j'y arrive de l'autre
côté si j'arrive à passer la ligne
d'arrivée qui était le golden gate
bridge la verticale du groupe the bridge
à san francisco alors peut-être que je
avec un peu de chance aussi bien sur tu
me sembles près et avec l'expérience
l'étude a attaqué mon premier tour du
monde essayais de censure le groupe dont
je vous parlais un peu plus ce soir est
donc ça cet effet le nom si du bateau
était quelque chose pour moi c'était une
limite pour communiquer et le messager
le bateau en japonais de données non
c'était s'écaille i was also one world
le monde
un seul est donc j'ai réussi et j'ai
continué et j'ai commencé à préparer mon
premier tour du monde et là aussi
plusieurs limites dans la limite dans le
projet dans le défi et
et pour moi la barre a été encore plus
haute et depuis 1969
il y avait plus personne qui avait
réussi un tour du monde en solitaire
sans escale sans assistance par les
trois caps à la voile la seule personne
était et faire robin knox johnston sérum
une audience en 1969
c'est le seul qui revenus et à bon port
et avec un bateau de 9 mètres 70 le soin
à lee est donc déjà il y avait ça ce
record cette limite a passé d'essayer de
le faire à moins de 3 113 jours et j'ai
choisi un petit bateau et ça c'est un
choix c'est une passion les motivations
sont différentes et ça vient du fait que
je voulais démontrer je voulais rendre
possible un rêve et démontrer que le
moyen les moyens qu'on à disposition est
aussi économique bien sûr parfois ils
sont importants mais son très relatif
là c'est surtout l'énergie connaît et je
parle surtout pour moi est commun dans
un projet commun dans quelque chose et
qui nous aide et nous on donne le
maximum de chance dépasser ses limites
ses limites personnelles ou des limites
physiques comme dans ce cas c'était
faire le tour du monde faire le tour de
la planète
donc c'était quoi ces records partir des
lieux donc ce que je parle maintenant de
là après j'ai continué j'ai fait de la
course au large terminé vendée globe la
jacques vabre la route du rhum c'était
sur des bateaux plus grands de trois
fois plus grand du bateau de six mètres
50 et celles des bateaux du vendée globe
et ça c'est le départ en octobre 2009
avec ce qui allait devenir le plus petit
bateau de l'histoire qu'on sache est la
deuxième personne à faire le tour du
monde
après c'est robin knox johnston le
record était battu de plus de trois
mètres de longueur et j'ai fait en 268
jours et pour essayer de faire un peu
une description de sa de cette limite
est aidé plusieurs limites dans la
limite j'ai essayé de répondre à trois
questions c'est quoi donc c'était quoi
ce tour du monde pourquoi et comment
bah quoi c'est très simple du parti des
sables d'olonne c'était aussi pour
rendre hommage au vendée globe
faire le tour de la planète ça veut dire
passer tous les méridiens passé deux
fois l'équateur
et revenir à bon port après plus de 4000
les 40000 km de navigation est donc que
plus de 22 mille milles et ça en
solitaire sans escale sans assistance et
sans pouvoir utiliser les passages fait
par l'homme donc sans passer par suède
ou panama donc tellement franchissant et
les caps mythiques donc sud de l'afrique
donc c'était le cap de bonne espérance
et après l'océan indien sud de
l'australie cap leewin l'océan pacifique
et après cap horn et la remontée
atlantique du sud au nord et pourquoi
les motivations sont différentes
je pense pour moi le plus important
c'était la passion sans ça je pense
qu'on va pas très loin et c'était une
volonté et une détermination et surtout
une énergie
j'ai besoin de me répéter et une énergie
cette énergique et gémit pourra pour
atteindre le l'objectif et j'ai pensé
l'étude est très important il ya aussi
une côte et qu'il faut pas sous-estimer
des d'imagination et de créativité je
peux dire et de curiosité ça j'ai trouvé
dans la ma préparation très importante
ma curiosité les changes avec les autres
personnes même si c'était compliqué de
rencontrer sir robin knox johnston donc
moi j'ai utilisé aussi la peur pour
dépasser certaines limites
mais pourquoi la peur parce que du fait
qu'il y avait pas beaucoup
d'informations sur des navigations de ce
genre dans tout cas sa lettre le
deuxième dans le monde
donc j'essaie de me faire peur sur les
conditions que j'allais trouver et pour
faire ça j'ai été voir des documentaires
par exemple des orc et qui servent les
vagues au sud des îles crozet et j'ai
été voir des documentaires des cargos
cassé par les vagues scélérates hausse
yannick de voir des documentaires sur
les oiseaux que j'allais rencontrer ces
des albatros qui allait faire plus de la
moitié de la taille de mon bateau le
bateau fait ce médecin quand il arrive à
faire trois mètres 40 d'envergure et des
cachalots des baleines est donc tout ça
pour moi c'était monde c'est un défi
dans le défi une limite à la limite et
dans ça j'ai voulu le faire quand même
un maire jean je voulais mettre ensemble
plusieurs choses ma passion pour la
nature je voulais aussi après on parlait
donc j'ai commencé à documenter j'ai
fait plus de
12000 photographie est survenu avec des
vidéos des centaines d'heures à notre
définition et après j'ai un bon aussi
pour commencer à écrire des livres et le
raconter le partager et un moment mais
la préparation faisant cette préparation
il ya eu une préparation mentale je me
suis aperçu avoir fait et très
naturellement
et c'était dans la préparation physique
du bateau dans la technique donc il ya
eu un peu de monde à de recherche à
faire ça l'est de la protection du
bateau le bateau ils devaient flotter il
devrait pouvoir avancer et je devais le
protéger je devais pouvoir leur part et
je devais pas avoir des dégâts et je
vais aussi me protéger donc toute
l'étude sur la technique les
combinaisons et parfois on a au mieux
l'occasion vous allez avoir l'occasion
de l'écouter quelqu'un ici qui s'occupe
de recherche spatiale
c'est peut-être un peu de projection de
ma part mais quand même il ya des
parallèles qui peuvent se faire car dans
ce genre de navigation on est quand même
dans un environnement qui d'un côté
merveilleux et magique et fantastique et
de l'autre côté est et peut être hostile
donc en quelques secondes ou quelques
minutes
si on perd le contact avec le bateau on
est mort il ya plus rien à faire il n'y
a pas de résistance il ya personne qui
vient vous chercher
et donc tout ça ça crée de la peur mais
en faisant comment se bat pour la peur
comment aller au delà comment
l'exploiter comment l'utiliser de façon
positive et il faut la transformer ce
que je fais un stress positif donc pour
pas qu'elle se transforme en panique
et ça je pense à une des
fondamentalistes et l étude donc essayé
de me faire peur d'imaginer des
scénarios des choses qui allait arriver
une voie d'eau un démâtage choses qui
arrivent et je vais prendre ça un
exemple dans le pacifique une vague
scélérate vagues pyramidales ab matin le
bateau il a cassé le mans troyes bout
j'étais à 2000 milles de l'île de pâques
à mille milles du chili à 1000 milles de
l'antarctique et donc j'ai réparé tout
seul avait que ça à faire je n'étais pas
blessé donc j'ai mis le décomposer un
peu le problème pour aller au delà de ce
problème et donc je les conduis
et évaluer et résolu à la fois en
partant du plus compliqué au plus simple
et donc gérer matin jérémy le bateau en
situation de navigation est une notion
plus important c'était tous les jours
d'avancé de faire un petit tas est
d'ailleurs j'aime bien une phase de
philosophe chinois c'est là où dessous
qui a écrit un voyage des milieux
commence toujours par un premier pas et
ses premiers pas un moment il faut le
faire et pour faire ça à un moment je
pense que c'est très important il faut
oser et on est accompagné dans ce
parcours surtout avec je répète avec
avec la passion avec l'énergie avec la
volonté avec la curiosité et bon après
c'était une préparation essayé de
changer et c'est lé projet d'une
préparation technique minutieuse c'est
ça qui m'a permis aussi de bien
connaître le bateau est parfois le
bateau il faut imaginer il peut
disparaître sous les vagues et s'est
vite fait de sortir de la zone de
confort et on a peur mais c'est dans ces
moments là que le travail qu'on a fait
avant que j'ai fait avant m'a permis de
faire face à des situations qui était
pour moi est incroyable que j'allais que
j'avais même pas programmer même pas
imaginer donc ça l'est delà du risque
d'hypothermie de perdre à chaleur et de
ne pas me nourrir correctement et à
avoir du bon sommeil avoir de la casse
quelque chose qui se casse pas pouvoir
repérer des vins tellement des bateaux
qui pouvait passer par là où des
icebergs et donc mais c'est le moment où
on sort de cette zone de confort donc
houleux le problème est passé qu'on
acquis une expérience et cette
expérience moi je les utiliser pour
relancer pour remettre à zéro les les
pendules à l'heure on va dire et
remettre à zéro la situation recréer une
condition de confort une condition de
bien être qui allen propulsait pour le
mil suivant la journée suivante
la nuit suivante et faire un mesures ben
là je m'aperçois que j'ai passé
plusieurs limites des limites de
navigation bien sûr des limites humaines
je commence à me dépasser ce que je
pensais pouvoir faire et
les limites de navigation ça va être les
les 30 degrés de latitude sud le 30
impétueux les 40 du rugissant les 50 les
50e hurlants jusqu'à fleuret les 60 m à
sur 10 ans définit 6/10 diraient les
anglais et après donc après le pacifique
mais il ya une autre limite pour un
navigateur monstrueuse qui est un peu
l'équivalent je veux dire le ver est
pour ça qu alpinistes sao crise n 1
solitaire c'est la grande paix du
passage du cap horn
et voilà et cette photo est par contre
c'est la photo que j'ai pris pendant le
vendée globe car pendant le tour du
monde à 6,50 je suis passé environ 120
milles aussi du cap horn tempête de nuit
donc j'ai pas pu prendre la photo mais
par contre cette photo c'est ma faute
aux biches deuxième passage de mon
deuxième tour du monde mais c'était sur
un bateau trois fois plus grand et ça ça
force le respect c'est on va dire un peu
une limite ultime
une satisfaction qui joie j'ai chanté
j'ai presque en vente est une chanson
fallait inventer une chanson en passant
ce cap
les albatros et kim escorte et sélection
de meetic d'une oubliable et après il ya
tout qui revient dans la mémoire il ya
je commence à réfléchir je retrouve à
bord mais mes livres de bord et je
commence à réfléchir sur ce que je suis
en train de faire et à la fin je
m'aperçois que si c'est vrai qu'il ya
une limite encore atteindre c'est
l'arrivée aux sables d'olonne mais de
l'autre côté je m'aperçois que le plus
important c'est le voyage c'est tous les
jours c'est tout les limites qui sont
franchis que j'ai franchi tous les jours
pour arriver pour parcourir un mille de
plus et quand je me retrouve dans le
froid et je me retrouve seul si d'un
côté ça ça peut faire peur ça me donne
conscience de la vulnérabilité vis-à-vis
de l'environnement qui peut être très
hostile mais de l'autre côté
surtout dans la remontée atlantique ça
me fait quand même penser à la
vulnérabilité de l'autre côté de l'autre
planète c'est pour ça que quand je fais
des conférences
j'aime bien le souligner et c'est une
planète qu'on doit respecter et c'est
une planète pour moi que en naviguant
j'ai vu deux
de magnifiques et je pense qu'on doit le
faire non seulement pour le respect
qu'elle mérite en elle même mais aussi
pour l'est les générations à venir je
vais résumer un peu les un peu les
éléments pour moi on était très
important et pour dépasser ses limites
qui sont aussi des limites humaines des
limites techniques des limites de
navigation pour un projet d' aventure et
c'est surtout la passion l'énergie la
curiosité je répète la curiosité car
permet même si on est seul avec une
équipe d'étudier de regarder plus
d'arguments de prendre des informations
de faire des erreurs de revenir de recul
et imaginez moi j'ai fais des check list
pour rien oublié et j'ai commencé avec
une check-list d'une feuille appelé deux
feuilles trois feuilles du foeil sans
faille et plusieurs centaines et c'est
seulement au moment que je coache la
dernière feuille la dernière check list
alors j'ai décidé de partir je vais
terminer avec un une phrase que j'aime
bien c'est de sénèque et des environs de
milan seneca qui a dit ce n'est pas
parce que les choses sont difficiles que
nous n'osons pas le faire c'est parce
que nous n'osons pas qu'elles sont
difficiles
merci beaucoup
quand même
[Applaudissements]